[Music]
good morning I guess fellow Python East
us so I'm gonna get started so I based
on the schedule that I saw I think a lot
of the presentations are operating at
like the five foot level where you're
really close to the material and that's
very exciting what I'm gonna talk to you
about it's really gonna operate up about
the thirty foot level and you'll see why
just so so quick some quick
introductions well the objective is to
talk about industry 4.0 I'm gonna tell
you about the concepts talk about
various aspects of it and what we are
going to have a deep dive into an IOT
example however my partner couldn't make
it so I will articulate the example but
unfortunately they won't be the live
demo part that we had promised all right
so who am i I'm reg Montague I work for
a firm called integrated project
management I'm a project management
consultant I lead lots of projects and
actually work out of Chicago but I'm on
assignment here in Indianapolis but by
way of background by biasing MS in
engineering science and MBA from the
University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
I took a quick little Python evaluation
and data camp and it rated me as
intermediate so I hope to earn your
confidence and my ability to code Python
I'm also a licensed professional
engineer in the state of Illinois I've
got a PMP which is kind of the project
management certification and the Six
Sigma and a couple of supply chain
certifications okay
IPM is a project management firm
headquartered out of Chicago with
various offices around the country most
of our work is in life sciences but we
do work in a variety of industries and
frankly most of my work has largely been
in manufacturing organizations so when I
first read about the industry 4.0
concept I thought I thought about this
right the Terminator and the premise of
the Terminator is all this idea that
someone develops this Network and it
takes on its own ability to make
decisions and overtime decides that we
are all expendable and it comes after us
so the robots are coming for us so so
the first question before we get into it
is what is your level of end of industry
4.0 awareness now we're going to do
something slightly different and many of
the presentations you attend you're
often asked to put away your phones this
presentation requires you to use your
phones so here we go okay so you go to
that address you plug in that code and
you start voting so we'll give you about
a minute to vote and then you'll see
let's see what people are and by the way
the presentation has a couple other
polls just to get your sense of things
it also creates the opportunity for
interactivity
Wow okay
okay give it about ten more seconds
okay so I'm going to move on to the next
slide so what is industry 4.0 it's blank
there should be a slide here
hmm so it's unsettling oh this is the
next poll let's go back marks
okay so that's the one and then you can
see the next slide oh wow
okay well it's just unsettling so this
is why I have a plan B I'll say there it
is right there oh that's why okay so you
know what let's talk about it since many
of you can see it oh there it is
alright so what's the first Industrial
Revolution I think everybody here
probably learned about the first
Industrial Revolution either in
elementary school or middle school and
that is the one we learned about where
you had steam engines come in to be able
to start doing some level of
manufacturing where there was some
movement from sort of agrarian economy
to more of a of a economy that looks a
little bit like this one when people
start industrializing things so this is
really the beginning of that so the
second one is I like to think of it of
sort of the marriage of electric power
mass production and along with that you
have a whole bunch of manufacturing
techniques that come into play then the
third Industrial Revolution comes along
and that is really around so the
beginning of computers in the workplace
the beginning of robotics from any
factoring and then the world we live in
today is the fourth Industrial
Revolution where you have lots of
technologies enabled by faster computers
lower cost of memory the the universal
availability of computing to everyone
and so that's your fourth Industrial
Revolution so you're also having a more
significant connection between the
physical world in the digital world in
many of these technologies
so was it include it includes all of the
east plus whatever else you guys might
be working on and others in Europe in
your which are skill sets might be
working on to develop so this is this is
a world of we're in okay so another poll
what technology so big you've been
exposed to let's see it's a lot weird
okay what happens with you guys for vote
let's see it's anybody voting I might
add to a pre-existing votes that I did
when I did this before but we'll work
with it okay so it's changing good
I think some of you guys might have
actually been voting ahead of schedule
that's what you got for overachievers
okay all right so as I see this I'm not
very surprised because Python lends
itself to data analytics and therefore
being connected to big data seems to
make sense Internet of Things of course
and AI so looks like this audience is
very well familiar with a lot of these
technologies so I'm not too surprised by
so this is going to be a quick survey
into some of the technologies but before
I get into that you know I did a bit of
research and found that according to The
Economist
Python is one of the fastest growing
language it is and it's used by many
many organizations you know all of this
but I like this phrase right it's
becoming the lingua franca of coding so
this at the moment at this point in time
seems to be the language that that's it
right now I don't know what the next it
language is perhaps some of you might
but this seems to be a language that a
lots of people are learning and lots of
applications are being developed and
organizations are using it to run it the
impact is that lots of these
technologies that are taking place or
that are being developed would be
underpinned by Python so one example in
and of things in this example 3m is used
in robotics to scan learning catch
machine defects and adjust so this is
used in a manufacturing application of
course in many applications and I'm sure
if I surveyed the room the lots of other
examples by the way my intent is not to
go deep in any single one of these and
some of you guys are very familiar with
so what's happening here so if you think
about companies organizations are
beginning to adopt these technologies so
specifically manufacturers are beginning
to adopt into Internet of Things and
digital digitization and if you look at
these statistics we have and these are
by the way old so I'm sure the the data
has moved on a bit but some companies
are thinking to invest in the coming
year some stage of adoption so and you
know we're looking about half the
companies either thinking about it or
actively engage in this and then there's
some organizations that are seeing some
results here we have fanuc that saved 40
million dollars by reducing downtime
subzero increase the speed of new
product introduction if you can imagine
you can get a competitive advantage if
you can get your products out to market
faster so that's one of the benefits
here and in this case now and that could
reduce labeling error rate by 50 15
percent so imagine you're running a
manufacturing company and you have a an
error rate of X if you can reduce that
then you can reduce things you're in a
way things that you're doing rework on
so this is this is fairly significant
okay ai not going to really spend a lot
of time here since you guys seem very
familiar based on a data machine
learning dito
augmented reality and virtual reality
you know I I actually attended a supply
chain conference a year ago and the
speaker got up on stage and gave this
really interesting application of
augmented reality that thought would be
pertinent to share said there's the
Vista capability of putting on your
augmented reality glasses right now for
gameplay but from
maintenance and imagine say you have a
maintenance person at a aircraft company
and that company needs to change parts
and this is a new part that needs to be
replaced in an airplane the maintenance
person is an experienced maintenance
person but they've never dealt with this
part and the augmented reality sorry the
augmented reality glasses can provide
them with the ability to make sure
everything is put together correctly
they'll have information about the work
that they're doing and because the FAA
likes to have things well documented the
whole maintenance activity can be
videoed and I thought wow that is
amazing now that's just one tiny example
where this technology can be used
because when you read about this it's
often about video games and
entertainment but this is a real-life
application that I think if everybody in
this room if I assume gets on a plane at
least once in their life would be very
appreciative of that digital twins is
the bits I think of it as simulation on
steroids where you can create this
digital twin that collects data and it's
in the twin partes you have a real
machine and you have a digital twin in a
digital world
but it's collecting data in a digital
twin and you can engage in simulation
activities but it also has that
connection to the real world where in
the real world you can then begin for
example predict when a machine might be
in about to break down which would be
really so I haven't spent time in
manufacturing organizations the thing
one of the things they hate most is when
machines break down unexpectedly so
they'll rather know that it's going to
break down in likely ten days we need to
replace it in that window of time let's
plan that out maybe we'll do it during
the weekend when many when we have lower
staffing as opposed to you know I know
more in the morning and then you have
all the staff standing around of being
unable to do anything so that's that's
the digital twin
hmm we have slow speed again oh there we
go
so then you got big data what makes it
big it's this volume how fast it's
coming at you the variety and the and it
comes in many many different forms
there's no longer information on a
spreadsheet it comes in unstructured
ways it may be tweets it may be you know
lights and all of these pieces of
information suddenly need to be analyzed
and when it thinks I mentioned before is
that and actually we're talking about
the the decreasing price of technology
over time so given that you can have
faster microprocessors higher memory at
lower cost unit cost you can collect
this data and because you're a Python
users you're now able to analyze the
data very efficiently so I would argue
that one of the underpinnings for a lot
of this other technology it's the
ability to have the data collect it
analyze it and use it in a smart way so
as a consultant it's difficult to have a
conversation that does not include some
notion of implementing so and by the way
a lot of this comes from a sort of
manufacturing distribution kind of angle
so you know you need to have the outcome
in mind I mean it's great to be excited
about the technology but in a business
setting companies are gonna make
investments and they're gonna want to
return and that return requires some
articulation of what those benefits are
likely to be so so these are sort of
five benefits that you might see by
implementing some of this technology so
you can have better predictability I've
actually worked on forecasting and
increasing predictability has the impact
of having to have less inventory on hand
so if you have less inventory on hand
that's less money out of your pocket
tied up in boxes of things in your
warehouse so you can use that cash for
something else
as a real-life benefit visibility there
are lots of organizations that that
wants that thing leaves the warehouse or
the manufacturing facility they don't
really know where it is and having
supply chain visibility it's very
critical to them the ability to make
decisions what should we do in a short
term
should we add capacity should we add an
extra shift long-term should we build
another factory these decisions or or
you know big money decisions in some
cases and organizations need to ability
to make those decisions and I would
argue that some of these technologies
and the ability analyze data can help us
do that more effectively speed you know
can be a really significant competitive
edge if you can get there wherever there
is either a new product a new facility a
new manufacturing method you can be more
competitive than your than your fellow
competitors obviously cost reductions
organizations are always looking for
cost reduction so the paint the
statement here is the key takeaway is
it's not can't just be cool it's got to
have an hour I so if we've just focused
some mid market firms 46 percent of a
adopting system to increase the
visibility and obviously enterprise
organizations that have bigger budgets
or also engage in this activity so when
I'm waiting here I would say that the
the impacts of you could be that it may
mean higher demand for your skills or
organizations are increasingly becoming
more digital you'd be the people showing
up with fire - people have never seen
fire before be awesome okay so you guys
see the next one on your device miss cos
I am waiting but I'll start talking
about it so what you see it's a little
graph here and the graph was actually
produced by Gartner it's a analyst slash
consulting firm there are smart guys
that
focus on allies and technology
technology trends and they came up with
this graph and I really like about it is
that it takes you through a kind of
progression of analytics so before it
was descriptive right this is I think of
descriptive as sort of like an annual
report here's just some data stuff that
happened last year we made money we
didn't make money
we sold a company we bought a company
that's what the thing wow I'm seeing on
your screen so I'm not seeing it on mine
this is really disturbing the next one
is diagnostic okay so then you can start
asking question of that annual report to
run your own analysis run your ratio so
understand what does it all mean
but you still have this gap between your
ability to do the analytics and a
decision in the actions and then you
progress to predict of the ability to
forecast but then again you still have
this sort of human interaction and then
this bottom section here prescript sorry
can trigger here prescriptive and that
is the organization essentially bridging
that gap and if the systems are in place
and the data is available the ability
for that decision to be executed in a
somewhat automated way so let me pause
here for a second while I wait anyway so
our firm is in the early stages of being
engaged in industry 4.0 so the examples
that we have a purely just sort of
training type of examples so I attended
an online training session in which the
people presenting it showed an example
where they had a machine running and the
machine was able to collect data on the
temperature within the machine and then
they were able to then predict sort of
the fatigue of the various components
with a machine to then decide what to do
with it and then they were able to ask
what if scenarios
in that context so let's see wow this is
really taking a while okay oh when I go
back okay let's see yeah so the the
availability and the ability to to do
something that day that suddenly becomes
really critical as you go down this
maturity okay so this last line is
really decision automation so if there
are things that you can decide in
advance you can hand over to a machine
you can then have the machine make those
decisions that are business-related
obviously their risk because there might
be unintended consequences I think some
of you might remember there was a sudden
financial sell-off because computers
were sort of pre-programmed to sell
under certain conditions and they all
sold and then it just precipitated a
decline in the stock market such that
the stock market had to be shut down for
that day so I think some of you remember
that
so the unintended consequences so
obviously there are some risk associated
with this okay but this idea of robots
are coming for us really for me comes
from this last line where decisions are
automated okay so if we sort of start
segmenting technology you know we can
start off with the left side being you
know fairly foundational stuff has to be
there that data has to be structured in
a certain way because there are many
organizations that are very immature in
the way they collect data the way that
they work with it within the
organization then we work as silos one
part uses an ERP system another part
uses a disconnected CRM system and it's
all bunched together via spreadsheets
this is not the most mature environment
to be able
to get to an industry 4.0 setting you're
still stuck in the past but the point
here is you have to pitch a foundational
technology your lower-risk technology so
that once in the middle I would argue
you can probably even add sensors to
that because you can have sensors
collect the data think about what to do
with that sensors are becoming
increasingly lower cost and then can
have these sort of emerging technologies
later on when you are at the right level
of maturity because if you implement
them in this sort of lower level lower
maturity environment this of rest you
might not be successful okay so how many
of you work for organizations businesses
yeah okay all right so let's take a look
let's see how well it applies so how
would you characterize your investments
in the next three or five years I feel
like this question might might have been
dead or Aska leave sort of a
manufacturing group rather than a group
of people that do technology for a
living but let's see aa scorecard we've
been working on one and I have one at
the end and then we'll just play around
with it okay everybody if you mind
repeating the questions for the
recording oh yeah sorry
so the question is do you have a
scorecard or way of assessing maturity
against the industry for point now yes
we have an evolving scorecard that I'll
present at the yet when it can I say
they're doing industry 4.5 an industry
4.0 well let's take a look at the
scorecard and then we can sort of make a
make a call ok so in terms of the survey
okay so this lot of investment in the
middle column and a lot of investment in
the blockchain and more advanced stuff
and then there's some people focusing on
the foundational
and smaller percentage no investment
plan or not or lack of familiarity okay
thank you okay so this is one example
where IPM was engaged by a company and I
didn't do this project this was I
interviewed one of my colleagues and got
a few of the details but it was a
medical equipment manufacturer and what
they wanted to do is really start
putting RFID sensors and other
technology in their organization to help
them really better manage inventory
product usage and the challenge here the
key the core challenge was that the
inventory wasn't something that their
facility was actually located at in
vain' so my colleague was very
successful in delivering on this project
I just don't have the final results of
it in the presentation okay this is
where we have the maturity model so
again experimental so I'm gonna ask you
still hear me a great I'm gonna ask you
to sort of take a quick look at this
we're not gonna go question by question
just think about where you think you are
in a sort of strategy strategy
development strategy alignment how your
people and organization business
processes how mature are they and your
technology and data so you know it is
possible to have a very good strategy we
have this plan that we want to execute
but maybe the staffing doesn't have the
skill set necessary to deliver so it
might be difficult to get ahead or you
might have you know the smartest people
in the world but you might not have a
effective plan right so it's possible to
for these things to be sort of
misaligned and then technology you know
from a technology and data perspective
you know if everybody's running around
with spreadsheets it might be difficult
to align the data as opposed to have any
fully integrated platform which you're
then you're sort of well positioned to
take advantage of
some of these industry 4.0 technologies
so just gonna we're going to do this
sort of in aggregate so here's the next
poll
okay so it's a votes are coming in I
would say that it's a little bit of a
self-serving argument but one of the
benefits of having consultants work with
you is that you may have the opportunity
to then improve in one of these
dimensions because you'll have this sort
of independent third party working with
you that understands where you want to
go and then we can apply some best
practices together so let's see you next
way I say yes because you have depending
on how the organization is structured
right so you might have companies that
are highly centralized everything flows
from corporate and everybody applies the
same standards then you have other
organizations to sort of run like
independent business unit go do what you
want to do just tell us how you're doing
make sure you deliver good financial
results but you're largely independent
so it's possible actually for
organizations to have different levels
of maturity across different divisions
of the company forward so organizations
are still trying to figure things out so
this is you know one of the execution
risks so that means that companies that
are trying to implement these
technologies are facing uncertainty in
terms of what technology what's the
business case how to best articulate it
a lot of the industry 4.0 technologies
are in its infancy so a quick story when
I was when the iPad first came out I was
talking to my wife about it I said I'd
love to get an iPad she says what are
you gonna use it for and I think some of
this stuff applies to this is that this
idea that that the technology is there
and maybe there isn't really a use case
that's all worked out right there aren't
lots of examples so there may be a
little bit of experimentation I may need
to take place because of that is maybe
maybe difficult to articulate the
benefits the KPIs in our eyes right so
the businesspeople want to see what the
likely business results are of this
investment but it might be difficult to
articulate it so there's a bit of risk
there if you think about technology
that's developed by a small organization
and they're trying to sell it to a big
organization it may be difficult to sort
of connect those two worlds because
they're different cultures and different
approaches and of course intellectual
property issues may crop up because of
who owns the technology who wants the
data all of these things might
complicate the dialogue so I'm just
going to cover a couple of these so in
terms of developing the strategy you
have to have one so here a few steps but
the key here is really organisations
want a problem solved and the technology
is some mechanism to solve it so excuse
me how much time doing how much time
okay oh great okay so so this is
actually the end of my deck but I'll
tell you what my colleague would have
told you about so you tell us this great
story he works at a company but he lives
on a farm on a family farm and his job
is to in the family farm is to feed the
cows so he went to an agriculture
conference and some guys wearing a
t-shirt that says Alexa feed the cows
and the guy who was wearing it was
wearing it as a sort of ironic joke he
was saying yeah there's some things the
technology just can't do it can't feed
the cows so he took it as a challenge so
then he goes home and develops a model
working model of Alexa connected to a
Raspberry Pi using Python coding to then
take action in the real world and then
he connects it to a shoot that opens up
and food falls and he calculated he
tells me using the Bernoulli formula
to figure out exactly how much time the
thing needs to be open to let out just
the right amount of food and this is how
he feeds the cows now he says Alexa
feeds the cow so ideally he would have
been here co-presenting but he just
unfortunately could not make it so I'll
try to address any additional questions
but that's more or less the conclusion
anybody else got questions for rich let
me bring this over to you hello
question on the digital tin twins how do
you see it being used because it'd just
be interesting for maintenance to be
able to work on that digital twin before
you work on it in the real world and
know that your solution is gonna work so
I think you'll be very useful in
maintenance activity so yes you
subscribe I think could be useful for
what's called predictive and
preventative maintenance because that
that's why you don't want a catastrophic
breakdown and that's unpredictable you
kind of want to plan for it so it might
also be very helpful to order your
replacement parts you know if you need a
gasket gaskets might be very inexpensive
but if you need a particular metal shaft
this particular dimensions you might
have long lead time and it might be very
expensive so you might not want to have
it in inventory just in case your thing
breaks down so be great to just know
that your machine is going to break down
at a certain time roughly and then order
the part in enough time to then plan out
the replacement I think the other
benefit is in the operation because you
know you're you're running your
manufacturing line you have all the
workers you've got the automation taking
place you've got the digital twin out
and the digital twin is collecting data
on that manufacturing operation it'll be
great to do is to then be able to take
the data from that digital twin and then
ask difference in error so kind of use
this gues simulation to then make
decisions that you might implement on
the
actual physical machine to then make
improvements so you might say hey what
happens if we speed it up right then you
get to figure that out but what happens
if we do a little bit more maintenance
preventative maintenance or if you
reconfigure the workers because we live
with one last line work or what would
the impact be would I still be more
productive or as productive as I was
before
so either to include improve production
or reduce cost
yeah Russians are red alright yeah
I think you said you had some background
in life sciences
a lot of its workers in life sciences
and I I do work it's life sciences too
but I'm gonna do manufacturing so I'm in
pharmaceutical manufacturing do you have
any perspective how regulatory agencies
public health officials things are
receiving kind of the emerging
technologies AI machine learning things
like that since it is such a regulated
environment sure I don't have direct
hands-on information but that's a great
question I do know that privacy so it
becomes very important particularly
during trials and I do know that
regulatory agencies are not typically
the most sort of up to date in terms of
technology because technology moves
ahead and we all sort of follow along
and we follow along at different paces
they also tend to be very conservative
so one has to be very careful and make
sure you connect with them before you
make any big moves all right we've got
time for least one more question
based on your experience in
manufacturing how close are we to a
factory with no human workers that just
maybe even a robot builds the factory
and it starts churning out stuff and
kind of like along that spectrum what
are the what are like the jobs that are
going away what are the ones that are
gonna stay right so I'm gonna answer
with a joke and a article okay
a comment about an article so the joke
is the fact of the future
it's gonna have a one person and a dog
and the person is to operate the
equipment and the dog to make sure they
don't touch anything but I think
different types of industries or
different stages and I think you have
you know very large capital intensive
industries that do require some level of
staffing right so chemical plants you're
always gonna have some level of operator
that's because there's safety concerns
there you know things blow up if bad
decisions are made but at the same time
he can then also have sensors to
mitigate that risk and maybe some
automated decision so I think you're
getting closer and closer I don't know
whether in some cases you can get to
zero but you can get you know can get
closer to that stage and I think if you
think about some of the things have been
in the press you know the this idea of
the decline of manufacturing I mean
we're still producing things you just
don't necessarily need as many people
and that's because over time companies
have become more and more efficient by
partly one of the reasons this
instituting automation in some of these
settings so I think I think of it like
Mathematica like as asymptotes right you
start you know you start getting closer
but you're not quite there yet and
different industries may be at different
stages any additional questions the
second party rush I mentioned which was
one of the jobs that are coming oh yes
so I think the jobs that are going to be
coming are the ones that involve dealing
with the data dealing with
so if you're programming a robot I think
NPR reported a field trip to an Amazon
facility where housing right and there
make some robots and people there and I
think over time the jobs gonna be more
important are the people that are
addressing the robots right and the
machinery as opposed to the people that
aren't necessarily moving the packages
physically so if robots can do more of
more of that work so I think some of the
jobs aren't going to go away might eat
more sort of traditional warehouse
personnel traditional manufacturing so
if you think about the trucking industry
right now it's a shortage of truckers
because there's just not enough people
to drive trucks around and we're moving
things all over the place but the moment
you introduce autonomous vehicles into
that setting and although but it might
take a few years but when the regulators
to catch up and everybody's happy with
them and then we all accept the risk of
autonomous vehicles and we're
comfortable with that then perhaps
driving types of jobs might not be there
and in in industrial settings of
planning people that drive forklift
trucks people that drive trucks to
deliver from manufacturer to warehouse
from one warehouse to the other to
deliver to your home so some of those
jobs might be you know might be a stake
in the future so I'm just sort of
thinking visionary
[Music]